Speaker 1: Let's get into the mailbag. If you
have something to say, you can email info at David
Pakman dot com. Sometimes we will pick something
from a YouTube comment or a Twitter message or
whatever the case may be. I want to start today
with someone who feels very, very strongly about
Donald Trump, even after Trump's announcement that
he is running. This individual, J.R., says Trump's
not running. J.R. says he ain't running. He can
announce all he wants, but he's ultimately not
running. I'm so sick and tired of his big, fat,
miserable ass. Enough already. Either stroke out
or have the big one and die. I don't care. Die,
old bastard. Die already. This is very aggressive.
When will the decades of coke and meth abuse
finally get them? I'm over it. America is. I'm
over it. America is over it. Just at least have
the dignity to go off somewhere like an old cat
or dog. Be your fat old self and croak already.
Please spare us any more of your ugly misery.
So J.R. is exhausted by Trump. But I have to tell
you, I believe that he's running. That being said,
we talked earlier in the week about a path in
which a failing Trump campaign prematurely ends
before the first primaries. And we explore that
in detail. Earlier in the week, I don't think it's
completely implausible. One other comment about
Trump 24 from Nathan The subject is MAGA GA Nathan
says in his announcement, Trump said he will make
America great and glorious again. Will he rebrand
his movement to MAGA? Very good question.
I don't believe you will, but there should
certainly be some kind of rebranding. The current
branding is really not so good. On the topic of
getting men out of women's sports as the right
loves to say. Alex had a really good thought.
Alex said, Hey, David, I don't believe Trump
would even have the power to ban trans individuals
from participating in the sport association
that lines up with their gender identity.
Aren't sports associations private entities? If
they allow a trans male to female to participate
in a sport formally consisting of majority cis
women, that is their own choice. With all due
respect, Alex. Yeah, this is actually a very
good point. So there's two issues here. There's
the claim to be about small government
conservatism. And yet on social issues,
there's no one that wants more government
involvement than they do. The truth is that
all sorts of different athletic organizations have
already had systems established to determine who
can participate. And what does it mean to qualify
to compete as a woman. This is not a new issue,
even though they want to make it seem like it is.
It's not a new issue. It's been around for a while
and many of these leagues have already dealt with
it before. Those running leagues that have dealt
with it. There are weightlifting around the world.
Okay. So it's not not a new issue. Secondly,
they say we want the lightest possible touch
from government. Government should only be
involved in anything when it is absolutely
necessary and in the public interest.
And one of the things they want to choose is who
is in which sports league. So that's part two.
It's not really small government. And number
three is absolutely correct that with many of
these leagues, they are completely private. The
one area where some legal scholars say you might
be able to kind of crowbar government in would be
when it comes to state college athletic programs,
things involving Title nine and in some other
narrow circumstances. But this is another very
good point, which is it's not even clear that
legally, whatever Trump imagines he would do on
this issue, aside from it being bad faith, aside
from it not even really being an issue. Scott
Galloway on yesterday's show told us that in South
Dakota they were passing a law about this and that
there is not a single instance of a, quote, man in
women's sports that they've actually had to deal
with, yet they want to pass a law about it. A lot
of problems with with all of this. And let's hope.
That Donald Trump never even ends up in the
position to do it. Steve wrote in about the
fact that all of those people that travel
around the country to all the Trump rallies,
they weren't invited to Mar a Lago for Trump's
big announcement. Steve writing in Trump fans from
rallies not invited to Mar a Lago. David Sir, I
found it interesting when I looked at the crowd of
people that attended the 2024 announcement at Mar
a Lago that none of the typical Trump fans that we
see at his rallies were invited. Could it be that
Trump doesn't like to hang out with his faithful
rally goers? Listen, I have said this before. Not
that we needed more proof, but I have said before.
Trump doesn't like the people that voted for
him. Trump is a rich guy from Queens, Manhattan,
spent most of his life away from the folks that
ultimately became his constituents and trying to
be nowhere near a lot of those folks. And now he
has built this persona where, I mean, think of it.
At age 68, he suddenly is religious. At age 68,
suddenly against abortion. He likes the voters
of Florida. He likes country music. None of it is
believable. It is all a character necessitated by
the reality that Trump couldn't win a Democratic
primary because there are some standards in the
Democratic primary. I'm not saying that the
standards are amazing or anything to write
home about, but there are at least some standards
among Democratic primary voters. Among Republican
voters, there are absolutely no standards.
And that's why Donald Trump had to run as a
Republican, despite the fact that he was probably
really a Democrat for most of his life. Next email
is from Greg. And Greg brings up something that I
think is completely implausible. Greg says Trump,
DeSantis 2024. David, I write to you with tears
in my eyes and fear in my heart. I'm very afraid
that Trump and the sanctimonious will make up in
time to join together on a ticket in 2024 with the
promise that Trump will back DeSantis in 2028. Do
you see that as a possibility? I really don't. You
know, sometimes we look at some of these scenarios
and we say statistically there's some sense to it.
Trump and DeSantis right now each have roughly 40
ish percent of support, depending on which poll
you look at. It's 50, 30 or whatever for the
Republican primary. The math of it should be.
DeSantis supports Trump. On the understanding that
Trump chooses the Santos's VP. Then the Santos
has a path to be president in 2028. The math of
it makes sense. What doesn't make sense is ego
and narcissism will not allow it. Donald Trump's
ego and narcissism and maybe to some degree Ron
DeSantis, I don't believe will allow that scenario
to become a reality. If you disagree with me,
let me know. I'd be curious to hear from you. John
wrote in. John wants to talk to me about guns.
John wrote in saying, I own 24 firearms, many
of them assault weapons. Hello, David. I'm a
strong supporter of the Second Amendment. I was
wondering if it would be possible for us to have a
conversation quote on your show. I don't know why.
That's in quotes about what the role of guns in
our society should. I'm guessing it means should
be including kinds of guns people should own,
including assault weapons, etc. I promise I
will treat you with the utmost respect. While I
would consider myself a strong conservative man.
I'm glad that it's he's not just conservative,
he's strong. I am generally open to other people's
ideas and feel I can be persuaded if I feel the
person I'm talking with can make a sensible
argument. My number is blank. Hope to hear
from you soon. By the way, please blurt out my
number. Yeah. Listen, we take calls once a week
and you can call in. This isn't exactly the type
of call we would schedule. But, John, I would love
for you to call in when we are taking live calls
and then we can chat about your perspective on
assault weapons. I am curious why someone needs 24
guns. Maybe you're a collector. I don't know. But
that's that's an open question. Caroline wrote
in about an issue with Instagram and this this
is horrifying that this is going on. I've told
you about this before, but it's still happening.
Carolyn says, hey, I know you're having you were
having problems with tick tock due to malicious
reporting. It appears that Instagram may have also
taken some sort of action along the same lines
as I received an error message on the app stating
the following David Pakman show can't be mentioned
because they have repeatedly posted content that
goes against community guidelines on false content
about COVID or vaccines. Carolyn says If it's a
problem you're aware of, I apologize. But I've
been a member and a listener. I don't recall you
mentioning. Yeah, this is this is insane. There
is no way to appeal it. Instagram's appeal
process. So here's what happened. Basically,
we published videos debunking misinformation about
vaccines. They were flagged by Instagram as videos
pushing disinformation about vaccines, which means
no one can tag us on Instagram when we try to
appeal it. There's an appeal process, but you have
to submit the videos in question that caused the
problem. But those videos have been removed, so we
quite literally cannot file an appeal. So I appeal
to you and the audience and really with tears in
my eyes if you work at Instagram, Facebook, meta.
If you can help with this, I'm desperate for your
help. Our Instagram is being hindered dramatically
because people can't tag us and they can't
share our content in that particular way.
If you can help, please email info at David Pakman
dot com. We have a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about so many different things. Huge
announcement. Our White paper on talking to family
on at Thanksgiving about things you disagree about
is now live and available for free. We produced a
guide which you can get at David Pakman dot
com slash guide for free. I have nothing to
sell you here. It's a free guide. People call in
all the time. They say, David, how do I handle
this? That conversation we have, like, it's
like a ten page paper got really, really good.
David Pakman dot com slash guide. Read it
before your Thanksgiving conversations.
Let me know if there are things that
should be added, modified, whatever.
Free. If people like these, we will do more
of these guides. We have a great bonus show
for you today. Join Pacman Qcom to get
instant access. I hope to see you there.